okay so um
we've got
a very good panel here this afternoon
from
the colleges and universities across
suffolk and into norfolk and we're yeah
i'm just just trying to check that yeah
because you're one one college now
aren't you i should know this working
for the lep
uh i don't know how you ran it this
morning was it just hands in the air
questions for the panel
is that how you did it oh
jessica go for it then
here she comes she's still moving chairs
hank
thank you
um
hopefully this is working well i just
want to say what absolutely how
brilliant it has been to hear from you
two students and i know we've got four
students but um hearing both you young
men and your aspirations and thoughts
it's it's really really
um actually
makes me feel better about the future
but um what i would like to ask each of
you um
what do you see yourself doing in 10
years time and i'm afraid i
i don't i haven't heard what you know
you you two girls but i just like to
hear what you two young men would like
to see yourself doing as you sort of get
into the swing of your careers in the
future
okay i'll go first okay
um well uh i i i have
this year i i started working on
creating an online business
and i've just been studying and like
learning stuff and trying to understand
and figure out stuff like
seo and like web development
in 10 years from now i hope that i would
have like developed this business
even further
and take it to new heights and
to grow its social media
and also what i would love to do would
be to get
real industry practice in
in a real like business environment
where i can actually apply the skills
that i've learned in university through
hours of like learning
um and yeah but i really hope that i can
convert my online business
into like a real physical business
eventually
and for me i i i i would like to be
somewhere
in 10 years time where i'm helping to
actively make
um
the planet more sustainable and
trying to
prevent and stop climate crisis and
and
i died to see myself in some kind of
well
that
that is
about practical conservation or even
perhaps
teaching the next generation about
why
biodiversity is so important and how we
can fix this climate
crisis
thank you so much you're very
inspirational
i'll make one comment from
firstly i
think i'd like to be retired in 10 years
that's beside the point but from
i mean you can comment as well but from
a university and a college perspective
what what these guys have shown
demonstrating there is a training for
the next sort of generation and
supporting as we all said supporting the
county and and beyond really within that
so that that's one thing because there
is as you said there's gonna be there's
a huge skills
shortage that is coming within this
sector that we as a higher education and
further education need to step up to
actually help
and well you guys and and others with
throughout the community coming forward
so that's an important and on a more
personal level it's my interest within
as professor is research and to identify
looking at some of the key issues that
are going on within society
my interest is in toxicology intoxicants
so it's looking at how we manage that as
well so it is again that bigger picture
that i
personally i tried to get across
certainly to thomas who i was we we were
teaching him yesterday about
lithium
ecological risk assessment and lithium
will be
do you have another question at all
matthew at the back um thomas a question
for you what can local councils do to
help with biodiversity
pardon i didn't hear that
sorry what can local councils do to help
biodiversity
i i think what councils
should can do is
i i think firstly they need to if they
can
to try and
educate more people about it and
why there's a
problem
um
because i don't think there's enough
said in the educational side
but i also think councils need to make
finding biodiversity and engaging with
biodiversity
more accessible
and so that needs to come from
better
transport
links to
places where there's biodiversity
hotspots like nature reserves but also
councils
have to be part of this change
in climate change if we go stop it they
need to provide
better
um
transport networks so that more people
want to use public transport like buses
to get to
universities rather than cars because
otherwise
how how are you going to stop that
thank you
mattie matthew at the back
hi there matthew ling suffer county
council i'm really intrigued i just
wonder in terms of education bit because
having very specific dedicated courses
for sustainability and i think one of
you mentioned about
trying to bring it across the whole
curriculum and i'm just wondering what
you're doing to embed
the net zero the climate change the
sustainability environmental stuff so
it's embedded across so that people in
early childhood studies
will use it as part of their decision
making people in nursing and midwifery
will use it as part of their decision
making as they progress through their
career
thank you
yes so as part of east coast college's
full-time curriculum there's mandatory
tutorials around raising that core
awareness
and we then involve employers around
master classes so for example we've got
last week we've got the fashion industry
coming in and working with students on a
fashion course around the impact fashion
can have on sustainability and how they
can consider
their future and how they embrace that
so we have plumbing students looking at
air source heat pumps this week we've
got electrical students who are raising
awareness around hybrid car charging
points so
it's core and it's contextualized
we're trying to link it to their career
aspirations
to get the hook
to make them understand that actually
they have got the biggest part to play
not only now but in the future
it's really important
yeah i would concur exactly with that i
mean at the present moment it is very
much on a
course-by-course basis so business
the business courses will have their
outreach to look at that and we do
certainly within obviously the wildlife
type type of courses and health do as
well one of the ideas and it's it's only
gradually coming to fruition is sort of
embedding it across the whole of the
university
and ideas putting forward and visions
going forward we're actually
you have
yeah if you want to sustainable global
citizen
they need to understand
the whole aspect i'm very much about
the whole aspect and that's
something i yeah i'm looking at and
building on because we have as i said
we've got buy-in from all over i mean
everybody's interested in it and it's
important to get that
and uh so i'm really important to see
how somebody within life science and and
looking at biodiversity how that does
actually link to no poverty
equality because those are the other
sdgs it's not just this it's a it's a
bigger
thing so yeah and as you said you get
people coming in and that interaction
which is
really vital
michelle
thank you um i just wanted to ask a
quick question about education funding
to help make sure that we've got the
right courses to help us
to deliver on our sustainability agenda
and
not just uh the traditional courses of
construction and engineering and
manufacturing processing but creating
hate network engineers of the future
is the education funding system keeping
up with that are we i can see some
laughs already but and i think this is
one of the challenges that we've got
we've got people who want to develop
these technologies we've got young
people who want to work in the
industries is there anything that we
need to do to help make sure that the
funding system through
the education network keeps up
in terms of fe you will constantly see
fe funding has been lagged for many
years and there is a lot around the new
skills bill jobs plans around how we can
make education robust
but it's not just about funding it's
also about the qualifications
so there needs to be
um a collective approach to awarding
bodies to actually say how current are
your qualifications
because the qualifications the elements
that attach the funding so it's it's a
chicken and egg environment of we need
to maximize funding but also we need to
make sure qualifications are robust and
current but also as an educational
provider what else can we do on top of
the qualifications
so we go above and beyond
and the college you know historically
was delivering the same qualifications
every year we now work with labour
market intelligence we work with
employers about actually what is the
changing need
so yes there still will be a need for
gas engineers but actually we're
evolving into renewables so we re
we it constantly needs challenge and
part of our curriculum planning every
year is we bring in employers and
sectors
to absolutely we justify why we're doing
it
hi yes i just sort of wanted to reassure
everybody that i think um there's we're
all part of something called the
decarbonization academy and that works
through the lab and we're just on the
beginning of
defining that over the last few months
and but that is really to look at
embedding sustainability and climate
literacy across
the whole of the region and within every
context so
quite a big ask but it's something that
we are collaborating on um as a group of
um learning and training providers
and i think from the university
perspective obviously
we're kind of on the same for you guys
with your degree courses you're not as
locked into a curriculum as you might be
on some of the types of courses so
there's definitely that flexibility from
um course lead course tutors to be able
to
in fact they must every year updates and
move with whatever is is coming through
within their their area of specialism so
um it doesn't necessarily always capture
um all the elements which as nick said
is why we're starting to work much more
across discipline so that we're getting
different schools talking to each other
and making sure that their specialist
knowledge is being pulled through into
other degree courses can i ask a
question is that right
just ask the question of you guys um
having worked in my kitchen for the last
20 months as many of you will have done
there's no doubt that the crisis as it
has been as as awful as it has been is
going to drive change it always already
life and business won't go back to
complete normal as it was before
and there's nothing like a national
crisis to drive innovation and change in
society just look at wartime
britain and how that change in technical
innovative terms and gender equality and
so on
there must be some
real opportunities now coming out of a
crisis we hope
for education and
academia working with business etc to
make some real changes
because
you know
my experience so far is
we were talking about the same things at
the opening green as county conference
15 years ago and we still haven't moved
the agenda on as much as we should have
done i get the impression now there's a
real opportunity because change has been
pushed onto us
and now can we can we kind of capture
that energy and what can we do i guess
do you see that
yes
ian that's quite a difficult question to
answer um but uh
talking yeah going back 15 years i read
something this morning in the in the
garden you can tell what i read
that actually the the word climate
change was first used in 1845 in the us
so 170 years later we're still
talking about it
but what change is coming there i i
think the change
is coming as you said we talked about it
and and
the technologies are there
uh but i think what what's happened is
that there is
it's sort of what we've got here
community
and the community spirit that came
through covered clapping for for nhs is
there and the power of community to
change
policy is what sort of i think is is
coming through more and more and that
did come after the war and have a major
event
because though we can do individual
things and this is what this is about
you know
heat pumps etc we do need and i'm afraid
to say those that that we do need
governments that actually
take responsibility and put in policies
and regulations this is my view i mean
i think i've shared what my political
views are already today
but that's what i i sort of think
because leaving it to the market is not
it's not it's not working it's been 15
years since we've known about this for
decades and it's been left to the market
and it hasn't really
well it it's improved our life yeah
greatly i mean with that but it hasn't
improved
by diversity loss so i think communities
coming together and working together is
the big thing that's come out of it
that's not an education side of things
but it's that's what i see as a it's a
personal view
yeah of course yeah i think um
but i think it can also impact on
education just with that community
element because if you think of
something like the institute of
technology that we're trying to develop
that's a couple of universities and
three or four different colleges coming
together developing the institute and
our students will then be much more of a
community sharing ideas with one another
so with the learning we've had through
the lockdown just simple things like
digital digital learning digital
communication that allows you know the
students who are sitting here in ipswich
to communicate with our students in
great yarmouth and lower staffed equally
with those in west suffolk and they can
all be within the same discussion groups
and having the same lectures and the
same opportunities
with the employers so i think that just
at a very basic level that level of
digitization is really going to help an
impact on
education
any other
gentleman over here oh you've got a long
walk again i'm afraid
well no one gets hang on we'll we want
to hear you properly
hi um so i was curious about what the uh
colleges and university are doing as
institutions about their own ecological
impact and carbon footprint and what
role the student bodies have had in
those you know
those actions
yes so in terms of east coast college
myself and kerry lead up the
sustainability
group
um of which we make sure that there is a
range of team members present not just
staff that want to get involved but the
ones we need to get involved and we've
got the student ambassadors as i
mentioned in the presentation and it's
an open door of challenge
research
inquiry rather than this is what we're
doing and it's very static so we've
revamped our sustainability policy in
the summer we've set ourselves some
really challenging targets around
biodiversity around clean energy
and sustainability in all aspects
whether it's our staff base how we're
developing our staff or our actual
physical resources so we've we've
revamped because i think as we mentioned
already
i will put our hand on our heart and say
college became a bit stagnant and slow
about what we needed to do in the pace
of it so we've really rebooted that from
governors to cleaners to students to
employers and we will monitor and we
will constantly push that through to
make sure it happens and we'll celebrate
it when there's good news as well
we actually have our sustainability
officers sitting right in front of me uh
justine do you want to comment
yes
maybe if you got to get them mike and
come
yes so um we've
obviously declared a climate emergency
and so we're looking to go to
um
for skate one and two to become carbon
neutral by 2030 um and then for scope 3
and the final remaining bits of scope 1
and 2 to be net zero by um 2050
and and there's a carbon plan that kind
of underpins that that's currently being
redrafted and to look at how we
financially achieve that um but also
that all-important behavioral change
piece
um we've been um probably not similar to
yourselves you know we've been
monitoring and measuring um all of our
utilities consumption wastewater and we
have a biodiversity plan that takes us
to 2024 um which is all about
sort of increasing networks we're in
quite an urban environment so this is
really important that whole 30 by 30
piece
we have waste strategies we're really
pushing now into the circular economy
and trying to look at that supply chain
procurement piece and there's a lot of
work to be done and for all of us and uh
it's it's not an easy journey but
uh definitely i think
this current cohort of students i'd say
i'd kind of
say similar to i think you were saying
over the last couple of years and i'm
noticing that with our student body as
well so we now have quite a number of
student societies i mean daniel's my
intern um so we've got a lot more
engagement from students and where
students go
the faculty follow so you know the more
the students shout if you think strike
for schools and this is the generation
you know these guys have just come in as
first years they were the ones striking
for schools and so we are now having
that group of um you know gretchenberg's
children as it were we're coming through
and obviously they're incredibly
passionate
um and we want to work with that passion
to make sure that our operations and our
facilities are as good as they can be
if not better
thanks justine
just just a just a plug i think for
the sort of educational and scientific
establishments in in norfolk and suffolk
and he's i've worked with a lot of them
over the last few years at the lab
if you were in america and you had the
university of east anglia university of
suffolk east coast college
new suffolk college
uh whatever else et cetera cambridge
university just down the road you'd be
calling it massachusetts institute of
technology mit or or silicon valley
wouldn't you it's that good the level of
science and education and academia and
research and innovation in this region
is second to none we constantly fail to
brand it and tell the rest of the world
about how good it is and and it's a
personal
sort of mission of mine to
contribute to doing that you've got such
a wealth of knowledge
and experience in this region and and we
just don't sell it enough we really
don't that's no disrespect or criticism
to anybody it's just recognizing the
strength of what we've got here really
yeah well this is where that institute
of technology which yeah you helped
fund is is coming forward to bring
that together because
we're aware of that and it is bringing
it together and it hopefully
we could we hear soon don't we
and then we can take that forward
but the other side of it and i don't
want to put pressure on justine but as
quite important parts of our community
both in lowest often in ipswich and
suffolk in general we should be leading
on this and demonstrating
and i think it was the west coast uh
west suffolk um
college we're sort of talking about
leaders coming in and getting that but
we need to give the advice and we need
to demonstrate from our own practice of
what can be done and what is best
practice
and and that's just my view and i i put
the pressure on to justine about that
because i know she can do it
thanks very much panel is that i think
where
if everybody's had their questions uh
that's a tremendous contribution to the
day i hope i think definitely and and
thanks very much to our
younger members today for you know
bringing us to
to sort of um
so bring up of what we've got to do in
the next few years
absolutely
i think we're going to move straight
into workshops is that right but you can
grab a coffee on the way and take your
coffees into the workshop
and have a little break as you go so to
speak does everybody know where the
workshops are
yeah you'll be shown apparently so
you can progress to your workshops
[Applause]
you